South Korea's parliament has voted to impeach President Park Geun-hye,...
...over a corruption scandal, immediately suspending her powers.
234 out of the National Assembly's 300 lawmakers supported impeachment.
The president's fate now lies with South Korea's constitutional court.
It must decide whether to uphold the motion,...
...a process which could take 180 days.
Park became embroiled in a scandal due to her relationship with a friend,...
...who is accused of using her influence...
...to pressure big business into making large donations.
The parliamentary vote, which effectively ends Park's presidency a year early,...
...means she becomes the country's first democratically-elected leader...
...to be forced from office in disgrace follows weeks of mass protests in South Korea.